we have a crowd like this it's a
u-shaped graph we have a line that's
called the directrix and we have a point
that's called the focus and we have a
point that's called the vertex now the
vertex is halfway in between the focus
and the directrix and the distance from
the vertex to the directrix or the
vertex to the focus we usually call that
distance P that's the focal distance and
the basic idea is that if you pick any
point along the parabola the distance
from that point to the focus will be the
same as a distance from that point to
the directrix the shortest distance so
as you go further and further out on the
parabola the distance to the focus will
get longer but so will the distance to
the directrix and those two distances
will be congruent so let's take a look
at this example and I'll show you what I
mean
so here we're trying to find the
equation of the parabola given the
vertex zero zero and the focus is zero
negative four
now I always like to draw a sketch you
might want to do the same thing to just
to give you an idea of what it looks
like so the vertex is here is zero zero
that's where the graph is changing
direction it's where it bends okay it's
the maximum or the minimum and then the
focus is at zero negative 4 so that's
going to be right there and you can see
that the parabola is always going to
open towards the focus away from the
directrix okay and there's two different
forms of the equation there's the x
squared equals 4p y form and there's the
y squared equals 4p X form if the X is
the squared term then it's going to open
up or down if the Y squared is the
squared term then it's going to open to
the right or to the left and the idea is
that if P is positive it would open to
the right if P is negative it open to
the left if it's this one here
x squared if P is positive it'll open up
if P is negative we'll open down so we
can see here that just start you know
rough sketch our parabola is going to
look something like this it's opening
down and that tells us is an expert
variety and you can see this distance
from the vertex to the focus okay that
distance is 4 so we know that it's going
to be x squared equals 4 y and the P
distance you can see this 4 I'm going to
make that a negative
four so that this is negative it's going
to be opening downward so our equation
is x squared equals negative 16 Y so I